welcome everybody near tragedy for pink
and her team after her show in Norway so
scary just hours after she walked
offstage members of her inner circle
went down in a terrifying plane crash
fire crews frantically doused Pink's
plane after it burst into flames minutes
before crash landing the singer had just
finished her set last night in Oslo
Norway while on her beautiful trauma
tool her manager and nine others
including some of her crew were enroute
to Denmark when somehow their cessna jet
caught fire and crashed just off the
runway miraculously no one was hurt and
pink was not on board you said that you
take your kids on tour with yes the mom
of two's been jetting across Scandinavia
and recently brought her kids to Europe
it's unclear if they were travelling on
this leg but Pink's told us willow and
Jamison usually hang with our crew they
have this incredible diverse beautiful
carnival of people my dancers and my
band and wardrobe it's just this gypsy
family of travelling people and that
part's beautiful the cause of the
accident is under investigation
pink who's known for taking risks during
her performances will continue to play
her concert tomorrow night in Denmark
does your family ever say can you just
keep your feet on the ground once
anytime about me and my husband it's not
gonna happen no pink don't ever stop
flipping and flying all over the place
that's why we love you
[Music]